-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
Turkey Day tradition stories
from you guys. Here we go.
This first one
is from @luckylizzy.
She says, "My mom makes us
get up at 4:00 a.m.
to dance with the raw Turkey,
holding it
by its wings and legs,
because it tenderizes the turkey
before it goes in the oven.
33 years now,
just dancing with the turkey."
There you go, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Lucky.
-It's a tradition.
-She's lucky.
-This one's from @thesophiashow.
She says, "My dad, brother,
and grandpa always fight
over the turkey neck.
To settle it, my grandma throws
it over her head backwards
and has them try to catch it
like a bridal bouquet."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-They're neck and neck.
-This one's from @megimonster.
She says, "My family has
a tradition called 'ham slap,'
where you take
a piece of ham
and slap an unsuspecting family
member in the face with it
while yelling,
'You just got ham slapped!'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah!
-You just got ham slapped.
-Pcht!
-This one's from @myjowilson.
She says, "Every time
someone gets nostalgic and says,
'Do you remember,'
my twin brother and I
meet in the kitchen
and secretly do a shot.
It's makes hearing the same
old stories way more fun."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I would start saying,
"Do you remember"
just to get them wasted.
-Keep on remembering stuff.
-Mess with them.
-"Remember when
you got ham slapped?"
[ Laughter ]
-Ham slap!
[ Thwack! ]
[ Laughter ]
-Ham slap!
[ Thwack! ]
♪♪ Do, ba-doo ♪♪
♪♪ Ham slap ♪♪
This one's from @gotskeells.
She says, "One time,
a random guy showed up
to our house because he typed
the wrong address into his GPS.
We liked him so much,
we've invited him back
every year since."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's great.
-Come on.
-"Hey, it's GPS Gary!"
-"Yeah! Hey, man!"
-"You look great, man!
Hey, Gary,
come here for a second."
[ Thwack! ]
"You just got ham slapped."
♪♪ Ham slap ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
[ Thwack! ]
-This one's from --
[ Laughter ]
-You remember when...
-@Dremmalive.
She says, "A tradition
we're trying to break
is that the last few years,
my 90-year-old grandma
has come downstairs
on Thanksgiving morning
without pants, saying,
'This old bird
wants some bird.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, without pants.
Ham slap her.
Yeah.
[ Thwack! ]
♪♪♪♪
-"Get up the stairs!"
-Hyah!
"I'm wearing ham pants!"
[ Laughter ]
-This one's
from @maddyceesarz03.
She says,
"Each person in my family
gets a personal pumpkin pie
before dinner starts.
During a random point at dinner,
my grandma will say,
'Pumpkin pie,'
in a slow Southern accent,
and the last one
to stick their face in the pie
has to clean the table
after dinner."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"P-u-u-u-umpk-i-i-in
p-i-i-i-i-i-i-ie!
-Ham slap!
[ Thwack! ]
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Ham slap ♪♪
-This one's from @girlgetsfit89.
She says,
"One year, my cousin
brought his
vegetarian girlfriend,
and she made us
give the turkey a name
and have a moment of silence
before eating it.
Eugene was delicious."
-Yeah!
-There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.